spaces like this
are a perfect way to begin
understanding what it's like to have
awakened states of consciousness
[Music]
so here we are at the museum
natural history in los angeles
and what you see are you see a bunch of
windows into exhibits that are
showcasing
taxidermical animals
and so you have some bears and some
deers and some
beavers and some elk etc
and so what you can begin doing is you
can view
every single one of these portals
as a
view into someone's perspective
so here's a portal into
one unique expressions perspective a
unique human's perspective
here's another portal into a unique
human perspective
another portal into a unique human
perspective another portal into a unique
human perspective
another portal another portal another
portal another portal and so on and so
forth
and so what you have is you have this
big room
that is full of portals into
unique human perspectives
and so this would be what it would be
like to be
with the mind of god to be with the
perception of god
is to be watching through all
eyes simultaneously can you look through
all pairs of eyes simultaneously
so you as this room are god with all of
these different
portals into unique human
expressions and furthermore so that's
god and furthermore if you wanted to
take it to the next level to the
absolute level imagine this room
is the absolute perceiving
all of the different gods
so this is one creation
one universe god this is another
creation
another universe another god another
creation another universe another god
and another creation another universe
another god and so on and so forth
and this is the room of the multiverse
this is the room of the metaverse
this is the room of the absolute
so these are the different ways that you
can begin
using analogies to understand
the awakened states of consciousness